Shure: 不能违法呀你
Shure: You can't break the law
Katrina: 我唱的是国歌
Katrina: I'm singing the national anthem
Katrina: 中华人民共和国国歌
Katrina: The national anthem of the People's Republic of China
Katrina: 没有唱别的歌
Katrina: I'm not singing any other song
Katrina: 我那那同学要来
Katrina: My classmate is coming
Katrina: 那同学他
Katrina: That classmate
Katrina: 我问他带不带吉他来
Katrina: I asked if he's bringing his guitar
Katrina: 让他上来秀一个
Katrina: Let him show us a performance
Katrina: 他有自己的琴
Katrina: He has his own guitar
Katrina: 还有电吉他
Katrina: And an electric guitar
Shure: 北邮这样的人我都会认识的
Shure: I know everyone like that at Beiyou
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: Another one
Shure: 是我知道
Shure: I know
Shure: 我说只要
Shure: I'm saying
Shure: 那个会吉他的我应该是都认识
Shure: I should know everyone who plays guitar
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Alice:你是哪个学院的
Alice: Which department are you from?
Shure: 我我是国际学院的
Shure: I'm from the International College
Katrina: 你问哪一个
Katrina: Which one are you asking about?
Katrina: 男嘉宾啊
Katrina: The male guest?
Shure: 我说那个事会吉它的那个
Shure: I'm talking about the one who plays guitar
Alice:啊什么你是你是哪个学院
Alice: Which... which college are you from?
Shure: 国际学院
Shure: International College
Alice:国际
Alice: International
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 就是那种中外合作的那个
Shure: It's the one with the international collaboration
Katrina: 那个弹吉他那个啊
Katrina: The one who plays the guitar, right?
Katrina: 弹吉他那是济南大学
Katrina: The one who plays the guitar is from Jinan University
Katrina: 然后我们俩保研认识的
Katrina: We met during our graduate studies
Katrina: 然后他在清华实习
Katrina: Then he interned at Tsinghua
Shure: 啊嗨我以为那是北邮的呢
Shure: Oh, I thought he was from Beiyou
Katrina: 北邮那不会
Katrina: Definitely not Beiyou
Katrina: 北邮那工作狂啊
Katrina: Beiyou people are workaholics
Alice:你认识你的上一界吗
Alice: Do you know your seniors?
Tasha:你把它拉这么长试试
Tasha: Try pulling it this long
Katrina: 你是
Alice:我不是
Alice: No, I'm not
Alice:嗯哦
Alice: Yeah, oh
Katrina: 你是
Katrina: 那他是那个女生是
Katrina: So that girl is...
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: 我搞混了
Katrina: I got it mixed up
Katrina: 还是搞一首热场歌的音乐
Katrina: Still, let's play a warm-up song
Katrina: 你能夹吗
Katrina: Can you clamp it?
Katrina: 我当时跟我的室友去KTV唱这首歌
Katrina: I went to KTV with my roommate to sing this song
Katrina: 可搞笑了
Katrina: It was so funny
Katrina: 许嵩最近在武汉开演唱会
Katrina: Xu Song recently had a concert in Wuhan
Katrina: 这两天
Katrina: Just these past few days
Katrina: 谢冰竹唱吗
Katrina: Is Xie Bingzhu singing?
Katrina: 谢冰竹
Katrina: Xie Bingzhu
Katrina: 把他拉上吧
Katrina: Bring him up
Katrina: 不然就我俩
Katrina: Or it's just the two of us
Katrina: 给人会笑场
Katrina: People will laugh at us
Katrina: 这要唱素颜吗
Katrina: Are we singing "Bare-faced"?
Katrina: 但确实是一首国民歌曲
Katrina: But it’s really a popular song
Shure: 变成情歌对唱了是吧
Shure: It’s turned into a love duet, right?
Jake:对感情你
Jake: About emotions, you know
Jake:两个人唱是吧
Jake: Two people singing, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 这是分男女生
Katrina: It's split into male and female parts
Katrina: 就是许嵩跟一个人
Katrina: Xu Song and someone else
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 我一对4唱好吧哈哈哈
Shure: I'll sing one against four, how about that? Haha
Katrina: 你1对4唱
Katrina: You sing 1 on 4.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 揉就这面试要做什么
Katrina: What should we do about the interview?
Katrina: 明天
Katrina: Tomorrow.
Jake:呃现在做做麻薯
Jake: Uh, let's make some mochi now.
Katrina: 哇每天晚上都有加餐哎
Katrina: Wow, we get extra meals every night.
Katrina: 好幸福啊
Katrina: So happy.
Jake:确实比较
Jake: Definitely.
Katrina: 麻薯好像可以放好几天哎
Katrina: Mochi can last for several days.
Katrina: 哦原来麻薯是这样做的嗯
Katrina: Oh, so this is how you make mochi.
Katrina: 感觉你在这几天也修炼了不少技能
Katrina: Feels like you've picked up quite a few skills these days.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Definitely, definitely.
Shure: 你回去直接可以新加坡
Shure: When you go back, you can head straight to Singapore.
Shure: 新加坡
Shure: Singapore.
Katrina: 新加坡开一个cake cake店
Katrina: Open a cake shop in Singapore.
Shure: 就叫EGO
Shure: Call it EGO.
Katrina: EGO cake
Katrina: EGO cake.
Jake:哈哈哈EGO cake可以可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, EGO cake, sure, sure.
Jake:EGO Bakery可以可以
Jake: EGO Bakery, yeah, that works.
Jake:然后所有加热材料都是显卡
Jake: And all the heating materials are graphics cards.
Jake:就主打显卡
Jake: Just focus on graphics cards.
Katrina: 一个蛋糕换一张显卡
Katrina: Trade a cake for a graphics card.
Katrina: 一个一个显卡换一张蛋糕
Katrina: Or a graphics card for a cake.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这个可以这个可以
Jake: This works, this works.
Jake:这个我喜欢我靠
Jake: I like this, oh man.
Katrina: 定一下
Katrina: Make a decision.
Jake:哎呀我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Katrina: 你最拿手的吧
Katrina: This is your specialty, right?
Katrina: 就是不用看谱的
Katrina: Without even looking at the sheet music.
Katrina: 你有推荐不
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 稍微热热场子
Katrina: To warm up the crowd a bit.
Katrina: 呃那个你要跳舞吗
Katrina: Uh, do you want to dance?
Katrina: 其实人多唱应该还行
Katrina: Actually, with more people singing, it should be fine.
Katrina: 能唱上去吗
Katrina: Can you hit the notes?
Shure: 女朋友会易眼前
Shure: Your girlfriend will be like.
Shure: 咦又唱这个破歌
Shure: Ugh, singing this awful song again.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 行那换一个
Katrina: Alright, let's change the song.
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Alice:你女朋友会来吗
Alice: Is your girlfriend coming?
Shure: 会吧应该
Shure: Probably, I think.
Katrina: 那把她喊上来一起唱
Katrina: Then call her up to sing with us.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 你女朋友是哀人吗
Katrina: Is your girlfriend your lover?
Katrina: 你女朋友是哀人
Shure: 我也是哀人
Shure: 就我意的浓度不高你知道吗
Shure: But my affection level isn't high, you know?
Katrina: 找你了
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 你们东北哀人是这样
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Tasha:嗯 你把它挤出一个球来你懂吗
Tasha: Um, you need to squeeze it into a ball, you know?
Shure: 没事他那个去
Shure: It's okay, he'll handle that.
Shure: 卫卫生那什么的
Shure: With hygiene and stuff.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 那个杨老板
Shure: Hey, Jake.
Shure: 把那个手机号给尼蔻斯发一下呗
Shure: Can you send that phone number to Nicous?
Shure: 路亚的
Shure: Luya's number.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 把路亚的手机号给那个那谁发一下
Shure: Send Luya's phone number to, you know, that guy.
Jake:手机号啊
Jake: The phone number?
Shure: 他联系不到路亚现在
Shure: He can't reach Luya right now.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 不能唱情歌
Katrina: Can't sing love songs.
Katrina: 为什么
Katrina: Why not?
Shure: 咋还在这
Shure: Why still here?
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh.
Katrina: 唱素颜多那个
Katrina: Singing "Plain Face" is so...
Katrina: 我也是被图书馆30秒弄过的人
Katrina: I've also been through 30 seconds in the library.
Katrina: 好吧不能这样
Katrina: Okay, can't do this.
Katrina: 换一首嗨一点的
Katrina: Let's pick a more upbeat one.
Katrina: 刚刚有听到一首歌陶哲比较简单的歌
Katrina: Just heard a simple song by Tao Zhe.
Katrina: 比较温馨的一首歌
Katrina: It's a pretty heartwarming song.
Katrina: 不知道难不难
Katrina: Not sure if it's hard.
Katrina: 你可以听一下
Katrina: You can give it a listen.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 之前有一首哦
Katrina: There was one before, oh.
Katrina: 但是没看到
Katrina: But didn't see it.
Katrina: 是一个英文歌的
Katrina: It was an English song.
Katrina: 保护环境
Katrina: Protect the environment.
Katrina: 这一首比较和平的全世界会唱
Katrina: This is a pretty peaceful song that everyone in the world can sing.
Katrina: 世界地球日是唱什么歌我想唱一句试试
Katrina: What song do we sing for Earth Day? I want to try singing a line.
Katrina: 刚打开小红书就刷到了南阳理工大学
Katrina: Just opened Xiaohongshu and saw Nanyang Technological University.
Katrina: 满足了我对大学的一切想象
Katrina: It fulfilled all my imaginations about college.
Katrina: 下雨了吗
Katrina: Is it raining?
Shure: 来抱着他吧
Shure: Come on, hold him.
Katrina: 我装一下我装一下
Katrina: I'll pretend, I'll pretend.
Katrina: 我要摆拍了你赶紧走吧
Katrina: I'm going to pose for a picture, you better leave.
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ahahaha
Shure: 非常快乐的
Shure: Very happy.
Shure: 有一首歌叫做水手公园
Shure: There's a song called "Sailor Park."
Katrina: 没听过
Katrina: Never heard of it.
Katrina: 要不就唱NEW BOY
Katrina: How about we sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 试一下
Katrina: Let's try it.
Katrina: 不知道歌词
Katrina: I don't know the lyrics.
Katrina: 不知道歌词我看一下
Katrina: I don't know the lyrics, let me check.
Katrina: 你可以不用看谱啊
Katrina: You don't need to look at the sheet music.
Katrina: 都
Katrina: Everyone...
Katrina: 唱唯一哈
Katrina: Let's sing "The Only".
Katrina: 北京民谣摇滚第九名
Katrina: Ninth place in Beijing folk rock.
Katrina: 行行行你弹吧
Katrina: Okay, okay, you play.
Shure: 我忘了词了
Shure: I forgot the words.
Katrina: 这调调是高了还是低
Katrina: Is this tune too high or too low?
Katrina: 感觉好跑调啊我
Katrina: I feel so off-key.
Shure: 有点难唱说实话
Shure: It's a bit hard to sing, honestly.
Katrina: 嗯 真的是
Katrina: Yeah, it really is.
Shure: 就最不难唱
Shure: It's the least difficult to sing.
Shure: 你你你要跳舞吗
Shure: Do you, do you, do you want to dance?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 可以吧这首歌好老好老
Katrina: This song is really old, isn't it?
Katrina: 你咋听你听听应该都能成唱
Katrina: How do you listen to it? You should be able to sing it.
Shure: 哎你还有没有什么其他想法
Shure: Hey, do you have any other ideas?
Katrina: 有没有什么简单点的英文歌啊嗨点的
Katrina: Is there an easier English song, something fun?
Katrina: 哎 唱黄老板的歌呢
Katrina: Hey, how about singing Ed Sheeran's song?
Katrina: 他的也很适合吉他
Katrina: His songs are great for guitar.
Shure: perfect是吧咱又开始唱perfect
Shure: Perfect, right? We always start singing "Perfect".
Katrina: 唱点
Katrina: Sing a bit.
Katrina: 开场开场爱上咱
Katrina: Start with a favorite.
Katrina: 计划几首
Katrina: Plan a few.
Katrina: 这个这个是替代那个跳舞的
Katrina: This, this one replaces the dancing.
Katrina: 就是还是晚上的活动
Katrina: So, it's still an evening event.
Shure: 我们就抛砖引玉
Shure: We're just setting the stage.
Shure: 如果
Shure: If
Katrina: 就是让他们跟他们的朋友说一下
Katrina: Just ask them to tell their friends.
Katrina: 也可以上来唱歌
Katrina: They can also come up and sing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 可以换BISS
Shure: We can switch to BISS.
Katrina: 我们可以搞个
Katrina: We can prepare something.
Katrina: 准备个两手
Katrina: Prepare two songs.
Katrina: 一首嗨一点的
Katrina: One upbeat song.
Katrina: 我看词嘿
Katrina: I'll read the lyrics, hey.
Katrina: 我觉得这首好适合晚上弹吉他唱
Katrina: I think this song is perfect for playing guitar and singing at night.
Katrina: 这可以当第二首
Katrina: This can be the second song.
Katrina: 我感觉路亚应该也可以
Katrina: I feel that Luya can do it too.
Katrina: 他不是英语还挺好
Katrina: Isn't his English quite good?
Katrina: 大家都可以唱吧我觉得
Katrina: Everyone can sing, I think.
Katrina: 这行这可以当第二首
Katrina: This works, this can be the second song.
Katrina: 开场什么的
Katrina: For the opening or something.
Katrina: 这个难吗你弹
Katrina: Is this difficult for you to play?
Shure: 可以弹 能弹
Shure: I can play it. I can do it.
Katrina: 呃开场好玩一点
Katrina: Uh, make the opening a bit more fun.
Katrina: 就是热场一点的
Katrina: Make it a bit more lively.
Katrina: 有那个陶喆的
Katrina: There's a song by David Tao.
Katrina: 呃叫什么来着
Katrina: Uh, what's it called again?
Katrina: 找自己听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard "Find Myself"?
Katrina: 可以试试
Katrina: We can try it.
Shure: 是这样吗
Shure: Is it like this?
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 他自己一般用这个开场
Katrina: He usually opens with this.
Katrina: 那你也可以唱你那个摇滚的
Katrina: Then you can also sing your rock song.
Katrina: 啊这好像有点难呃
Katrina: Ah, this seems a bit difficult, uh.
Shure: 我想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Katrina: 这唱的
Katrina: The singing part.
Katrina: 在中间
Katrina: In the middle.
Shure: 咱俩咱俩呱然后
Shure: We two, we two, gua, and then.
Katrina: 你搜一下
Katrina: You search it.
Katrina: 谈陶喆的普通朋友是最难的选择
Katrina: Talking about David Tao's "Ordinary Friend" is the hardest choice.
Katrina: 我朋友给我
Katrina: My friend gave it to me.
Katrina: 哦耶
Katrina: Oh yeah.
Shure: 这个好简单啊
Shure: This is so simple.
Katrina: 很简单吗
Katrina: Is it simple?
Shure: 我不知道这谱子是太简单还是怎么着
Shure: I don't know if this sheet music is too simple or what.
Katrina: 这唱不了
Katrina: I can't sing this.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 不能用纯吉他来伴奏
Katrina: You can't just use a guitar for accompaniment.
Katrina: 这个需要背景
Katrina: This needs a background.
Katrina: 嗯纯吉他的
Katrina: Hmm, just pure guitar.
Katrina: 摇滚的要么就唱张璇
Katrina: For rock, you could sing Zhang Xuan.
Katrina: 也不算吧
Katrina: Maybe not, though.
Shure: 我的宝贝宝贝
Shure: My baby, my baby.
Katrina: 这个好适合吉他唱
Katrina: This one is good for guitar.
Katrina: 眼睛像哄睡
Katrina: Eyes like lulling to sleep.
Katrina: 真的吗这这也好听
Katrina: Really? This sounds good too.
Katrina: 嗯这很适合唱给女朋友听啊
Katrina: Hmm, this is great to sing to a girlfriend.
Katrina: 要不唱告告五人的
Katrina: Or sing something by G5SH.
Katrina: 适合用吉他吗
Katrina: Suitable for guitar?
Katrina: 怎么啦我就是把嗓子给吃了
Katrina: What's wrong? I just ruined my voice.
Katrina: 你家唱歌就是会自动变人家是变夹
Katrina: In your house, singing automatically changes. For others, it becomes falsetto.
Katrina: 你是
Katrina: You are...
Shure: 我什么都会变
Shure: I can change into anything.
Shure: 特别油的那种
Shure: Especially that oily kind.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 哎哟 你好愁啊
Katrina: Oh my, you look so worried.
Katrina: 还给自己加的特效呢
Katrina: You even added special effects for yourself.
Shure: 特别特别油的最后一幕
Shure: That last scene was especially, especially oily.
Shure: 可多特别特别油的
Shure: There are so many particularly oily parts.
Katrina: 哎这个泪桥当时有那个街头弹唱吧
Katrina: Hey, wasn't there a street performance of "Tear Bridge"?
Katrina: 但这个好一啊
Katrina: But this one is really good.
Katrina: 唱得
Katrina: The singing is...
Katrina: 我给你看我当时就是听那个
Katrina: I'll show you, I was listening to that back then.
Katrina: 什么嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: What, hmm, hmm, hmm...
Katrina: 泪桥那个
Katrina: "Tear Bridge."
Katrina: 泪桥 有一阵子火
Katrina: "Tear Bridge" was popular for a while.
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你真不像个哀人素质
Shure: 那我切试一眼试一眼
Shure: Let me try it out, try it out.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哎呀不知道他用的是哪个谱子
Katrina: Oh, I don't know which sheet music he used.
Katrina: 就是调调是这样 女生版很好听
Katrina: It's like this, the female version is really nice.
Katrina: 你搜女生版的
Katrina: Search for the female version.
Katrina: 我给你听伍佰的原唱是什么样的
Katrina: Let me play you the original song by Wu Bai.
Katrina: 对对对就是这个感觉
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, this is the vibe.
Shure: 你先把这个关了
Shure: Turn this off first.
Katrina: 还是刚刚那个好听
Katrina: The previous one sounded better.
Katrina: 你能听出这个音啊
Katrina: Can you hear this note?
Katrina: 好神奇
Katrina: So amazing.
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 嗯你自己调啦等
Katrina: Yeah, you adjust it yourself.
Katrina: 等一下我要开歌词
Katrina: Wait, I need to turn on the lyrics.
Katrina: 他这是不是改编吧
Katrina: Did he rearrange this?
Katrina: 这个也是一抹神曲
Katrina: This is also a classic hit.
Katrina: 当然是
Katrina: Of course it is.
Katrina: 但是有了Perfect再选这个不好吧
Katrina: But with "Perfect," choosing this one isn't great, right?
Katrina: 这难吗
Katrina: Is this difficult?
Katrina: 这你这也不能我唱你也得唱
Katrina: You can't just make me sing alone, you have to sing too.
Katrina: 我不敢一个人独唱
Katrina: I'm too scared to solo.
Katrina: 就我目前唱歌的水平不敢一个人
Katrina: With my current singing level, I can't solo.
Katrina: 每天都非常的随便感觉
Katrina: Every day feels so casual.
Shure: 我们egou life就是白兰英来了
Shure: Our egou life is like the White Orchid coming.
Shure: 人类为什么会腿吗
Shure: Why do humans have legs?
Katrina: ai呀
Katrina: Oh my.
Katrina: 上班
Katrina: Going to work.
Katrina: 就是爱你好像也挺适合弹唱的
Katrina: "Just Love You" seems quite suitable for playing and singing.
Katrina: 因为我看现场他就自己弹
Katrina: Because I saw him play it live by himself.
Katrina: 陶喆的就是爱你
Katrina: David Tao's "Just Love You."
Katrina: 假装自已弹弹
Katrina: Pretend to play it yourself.
Katrina: 我我我之前练这吉他我就半途而废
Katrina: I, I, I gave up on practicing guitar before.
Katrina: 是因为我老按不紧
Katrina: Because I couldn't press hard enough.
Shure: 有可能能琴有关系
Shure: Maybe it's the guitar's issue.
Shure: 我总感觉这个镜子照人会偏高
Shure: I always feel this mirror makes people look taller.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 那我觉得我还挺好看的
Katrina: But I think I look pretty good.
Katrina: 原来是假的
Katrina: So it's fake?
Shure: 我靠真的
Shure: Seriously, really.
Shure: 他会把别人照高好多
Shure: It makes others look much taller.
Shure: 就我这个头发永远是在在那是
Shure: Like my hair is always up there.
Shure: 你看哦
Shure: See?
Katrina: 是假这什么原理啊
Katrina: What's the principle behind this?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Katrina: 看唯一怎么唱
Katrina: See how the only one sings.
Shure: 就非得唱一些伊某小曲的
Shure: Just have to sing some folk tunes.
Katrina: 焰火
Katrina: Fireworks.
Katrina: 假装吉他
Katrina: Pretend guitar.
Katrina: 这能用这没法用吉他弹出来
Katrina: This can't be played on a guitar.
Katrina: 然后后面背景音乐很那个
Katrina: And then the background music is very...
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 本来说今天晚上一定要把论文写完
Shure: I originally planned to finish the paper tonight.
Shure: 我现在好困
Shure: Now I'm so sleepy.
Katrina: 你啊
Katrina: You...
Katrina: 先泡咖啡
Katrina: Make some coffee first.
Shure: 现在
Shure: Right now?
Shure: 雨宣
Shure: Yuxuan.
Shure: 先把这个明天的定下来
Shure: Let's finalize this for tomorrow first.
Shure: 然后再再
Shure: Then we can...
Shure: 随便弹
Shure: Play freely.
Katrina: 就是第一首perfect应该没问题
Katrina: The first song, "Perfect," should be fine.
Shure: 真的perfect
Shure: Really perfect.
Katrina: 嗯p嗯
Katrina: Hmm, P, hmm.
Shure: pp一下吧没问题
Shure: Just PP it, no problem.
Katrina: 泪桥估计嗯最好选大家都会的
Katrina: "Tear Bridge" is probably... it's better to choose something everyone knows.
Katrina: 泪桥估计比较不是小众
Katrina: "Tear Bridge" is relatively not that mainstream.
Katrina: 嗯冷门一点
Katrina: A bit niche.
Katrina: 唯一跟唯一大家也会点
Katrina: "The Only One" is also something everyone knows a bit.
Katrina: 唯一和perfect二选一
Katrina: Choose between "The Only One" and "Perfect".
Katrina: 欢快一点的嗯
Katrina: Something more upbeat.
Jake:咋的唱累了
Jake: Tired of singing?
Shure: 我现在在思考
Shure: I'm thinking right now.
Katrina: 我现在在思考
Katrina: I'm thinking right now.
Shure: 定下歌曲
Shure: Finalizing the song.
Jake:自己作词
Jake: Write your own lyrics?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 你就唱草履虫拉倒吧
Katrina: Just sing "Protozoa" and be done with it.
Jake:你把词写了让人唱
Jake: You write the lyrics and let someone else sing.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Jake:这是我刚刚
Jake: This is what I just...
Katrina: 然后看看看看刚
Katrina: Then look, look, look.
Jake:学习的
Jake: Studying.
Tasha:老师做的
Tasha: The teacher made it.
Tasha:杨老师做的
Tasha: Teacher Yang made it.
Jake:学习的
Jake: I learned it.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:你有没有发现你没有带筷子上来
Tasha: Did you notice you didn't bring chopsticks?
Tasha:大家怎么吃啊
Tasha: How is everyone supposed to eat?
Katrina: 这已经做好了
Katrina: It's already done.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 好厉害啊
Katrina: So impressive.
Katrina: 这东西做的很快吗居然
Katrina: Did you make this so quickly?
Jake:这东西做的我馋死了
Jake: This stuff makes me so hungry.
Lucia:所就他说就是它很难判断
Lucia: So, he said it's hard to judge.
Jake:我靠满手的这个
Jake: Damn, my hands are full of this.
Shure: 面
Shure: Dough.
Jake:黏的
Jake: Sticky.
Katrina: 我要拍一张照片
Katrina: I want to take a picture.
Jake:可粘了洗了10分钟的手
Jake: It's so sticky, I washed my hands for 10 minutes.
Katrina: 哎 露西和爱丽丝呢
Katrina: Hey, where are Lucia and Alice?
Jake:他要是 哎露西呢
Jake: He wants to... Hey, where's Lucia?
Tasha:我们就坐在这是吗
Tasha: Are we just sitting here?
Jake:我们就坐在这
Jake: We're just sitting here.
Tasha:你要不要把大垫子拖出来
Tasha: Do you want to pull out the big mat?
Jake:大垫子
Jake: Big mat?
Shure: 就把那个
Shure: Just that one.
Jake:哦你的那个大垫子也用不着吧
Jake: Oh, you don't need your big mat, do you?
Tasha:行
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:就这个足够了
Jake: This one is enough.
Katrina: 那就一起讨论呗
Katrina: Let's discuss this together.
Shure: 露西亚你会唱是吧
Shure: Lucia, you can sing, right?
Katrina: 他不是露西亚
Katrina: He's not Lucia.
Katrina: 他是微微
Katrina: He's Weiwei.
Shure: 你叫什么露西亚
Shure: Why do you call yourself Lucia?
Katrina: 我是子轩
Katrina: I'm Zixuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我是子轩
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm Zixuan.
Jake:子轩好 你好子轩
Jake: Zixuan, nice to meet you.
Tasha:你完了
Tasha: You're finished.
Jake:你好子轩
Jake: Hello, Zixuan.
Jake:不 不 不
Jake: No, no, no.
Katrina: 他是露西亚我是
Katrina: He's Lucia, and I'm...
Tasha:我叫什么
Tasha: What's my name?
Jake:我是露西亚
Jake: I'm Lucia.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 你你叫塔莎
Shure: Your name is Tasha.
Jake:我叫什么
Jake: What's my name?
Jake:我叫露西亚
Jake: My name is Lucia.
Shure: 你叫Jing Kang
Shure: Your name is Jing Kang.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: What the heck?
Tasha:他就只能叫他有他
Tasha: He can only call himself that.
Tasha:他有英文名吗
Tasha: Does he have an English name?
Shure: Jing Kang
Shure: Jing Kang.
Tasha:你有英文名吗
Tasha: Do you have an English name?
Jake:我可以有
Jake: I can have one.
Jake:给给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Shure: JK young
Shure: JK young.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:我靠
Jake: What the heck?
Shure: number seven JKyoung
Shure: Number seven JKyoung.
Jake:为什么seven
Jake: Why seven?
Jake:为什么是seven啊
Jake: Why is it seven?
Shure: 没有就是脑袋里面第一个蹦的
Shure: No reason, it's just the first thing that popped into my head.
Shure: 就是number seven
Shure: Just number seven.
Shure: 韦世豪哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Wei Shihao, hahaha.
Shure: 什么你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: What? Don't you know this joke?
Jake:再说一遍
Jake: Say it again.
Shure: number seven韦世豪
Shure: Number seven Wei Shihao.
Jake:韦世豪我知道了啊
Jake: Wei Shihao, I know.
Shure: 然后哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Then, hahaha.
Jake:我上回看到踢球了
Jake: I saw him playing soccer last time.
Jake:在那个中国队踢平新加坡
Jake: When China tied with Singapore.
Jake:逼平新加坡啊
Jake: Forced a draw with Singapore.
Jake:对中国国足
Jake: Yeah, the Chinese national team.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Katrina: 想一首大家都会的欢快的歌
Katrina: Think of a cheerful song everyone knows.
Shure: 你们也可以唱你家乡的歌
Shure: You can also sing a song from your hometown.
Tasha:那必须要唱那种EMO神曲
Tasha: It has to be an EMO anthem.
Katrina: EMO选了一个
Katrina: EMO picked one.
Katrina: 那个安静一点
Katrina: A quieter one.
Katrina: 要么唯一
Katrina: Either "The Only".
Katrina: 要么就那个perfect
Katrina: Or "Perfect".
Katrina: 就黄老板那个
Katrina: About Nicous
Katrina: 应该这个
Katrina: Should be this one
Katrina: 这两个大家都比较熟吧
Katrina: These two are familiar to everyone, right?
Shure: 那唱那什么吧
Shure: Let's sing that song
Shure: 唱卡丘莎
Shure: Sing "Katyusha"
Shure: 你家乡的小曲
Shure: Your hometown folk song
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Think and use your smart little brain
Katrina: 看看你刚刚那个new boy
Katrina: Check out that "new boy"
Katrina: new boy
Katrina: New boy
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听了
Katrina: The two of us sound terrible singing
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听
Katrina: We sound terrible singing
Tasha:他不难听
Tasha: He doesn't sound bad
Tasha:是这个意思吗
Tasha: Is that what you mean?
Shure: 听过吗
Shure: Have you heard it?
Shure: 是呀哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha
Katrina: 这可这人多一点
Katrina: There are more people here
Shure: 你觉得唱歌如何
Shure: How do you feel about singing?
Tasha:非常不好听
Tasha: It's really bad
Shure: 我们唱那首西城男孩 吧
Shure: Let's sing that Westlife song
Katrina: 好就是
Katrina: Okay, then
Katrina: 好这个我会打
Katrina: Okay, I can play this
Shure: 好这个我不会弹
Shure: Okay, I can't play this
Katrina: 这个太难了他明白
Katrina: This is too hard, he gets it
Katrina: 这不嗨呀我以为这个摇滚的会嗨一点
Katrina: This isn't lively, I thought rock would be more exciting
Katrina: 到了专业的余额是吧
Katrina: Are we at the professional limit?
Katrina: 这样给你拍一张
Katrina: Let me take a picture for you
Katrina: 上小红书走了
Katrina: Going on Little Red Book
Shure: 这根本就不可以
Shure: This is not feasible at all
Shure: 用一把木的吉他给他
Shure: Give him a wooden guitar
Shure: 就是那种欢快跳搓
Shure: Just like those cheerful dances
Katrina: 哎小陈夏天呢
Katrina: Hey, where's Chen Xia in summer?
Katrina: 叫什么歌来着
Katrina: What's the song called again?
Shure: 水手公园那个旮旯乐队
Shure: Sailor Park, that corner band
Shure: 哈哈确实哈哈
Shure: Haha, indeed, haha
Katrina: 这能用吉他弹出来吗
Katrina: Can this be played with a guitar?
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Probably
Katrina: 上春晚
Katrina: On the Spring Festival Gala
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Katrina: 海域恋你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of "Ocean Love"?
Katrina: 海域恋也行
Katrina: "Ocean Love" works too.
Katrina: 那就这个开场
Katrina: Then let's start with this one.
Katrina: 这个就大家一起唱
Katrina: Everyone can sing this together.
Katrina: 这听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard this?
Katrina: 孙燕姿的第一天
Katrina: It's Sun Yanzi's "First Day."
Shure: 心燥的人
Shure: For the restless people.
Katrina: 还下雨嘞这个人听过吗
Katrina: And it's raining. Have you heard this one?
Shure: 塔莎给的议建
Shure: Tasha's suggestion.
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't heard it?
Katrina: 感觉这歌挺好唱
Katrina: Feels like this song is easy to sing.
Katrina: 试一下不
Katrina: Want to try it?
Jake:这得一群人一起唱然后在啊啊啊
Jake: This needs a group to sing together and then, ah ah ah.
Jake:你这是蓝莓味的吗
Jake: Is that blueberry flavored?
Katrina: 哪首歌啊
Katrina: Which song is that?
Shure: 周楚除三害
Shure: "Zhou Chu Eliminates the Three Harms."
Katrina: 哦知道知道
Katrina: Oh, I know that one.
Katrina: 但我没看
Katrina: But I haven't watched it.
Shure: 就是前段时间特别火的那个
Shure: It was really popular a while ago.
Shure: 棒棒棒挨个打死
Shure: He went around hitting everyone.
Shure: 好吧 那得想想
Shure: Alright, let's think about it.
Katrina: 开场
Katrina: Opening.
Katrina: 一般那开场还远着
Katrina: Usually, the opening is still far away.
Katrina: 我们居然用我的开
Katrina: We actually used my opening.
Katrina: 我的未来式开过
Katrina: Used "My Future" before.
Katrina: 哈哈好像那个
Katrina: Haha, it seems like that.
Katrina: 他是不是手机静音 我有时候会手机静音自已没发现
Katrina: Is his phone on silent? I sometimes put my phone on silent and don't realize it.
Shure: 开心超人听过吗
Shure: Have you heard of "Happy Superman"?
Katrina: 我有时候会
Katrina: I sometimes do.
Katrina: 手机应该听过
Katrina: Should have heard it on the phone.
Katrina: 应该 听过
Katrina: Should have heard it.
Tasha:哦我知道那个
Tasha: Oh, I know that one.
Alice:我一直手机在静音
Alice: My phone is always on silent.
Katrina: 哎 可以
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Shure: 听过吗这首歌
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Jake:听过
Jake: Heard it.
Katrina: 好找这种耳熟能祥家喻户晓的
Katrina: It's easy to find these familiar, well-known ones.
Katrina: 哎怎么了
Katrina: Hey, what's up?
Katrina: 门口吗 3
Katrina: At the door?
Jake:人类都记住了
Jake: Everyone remembers it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哎呀回来啦
Jake: Oh, you're back!
Jake:上吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:来坐
Jake: Come, have a seat.
Jake:大伙现在在讨论
Jake: Everyone is discussing right now.
Jake:哎最后一天唱点啥
Jake: Hey, what should we sing on the last day?
Jake:这咱就不跳舞了
Jake: We won't be dancing.
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Can your friends sing?
Lucia:卡拉OK的唱法吗
Lucia: Like karaoke singing?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Just that kind of singing.
Lucia:不会弹吉他
Lucia: Can't play the guitar.
Katrina: 不用不用唱
Katrina: No need, no need to play.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: He has a sound system anyway.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just use that.
Katrina: 唱歌就搞个话筒
Katrina: For singing, just get a microphone.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: And then singing can also get you something.
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: With a proper singing style.
Shure: 蛋黄的小裙
Shure: The little yellow dress.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One song to start with something lively.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: Another song for the evening, something slow.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the opening, listen to this.
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of Happy Hero?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure: 结尾想好
Shure: Think about the ending.
Jake:哈哈哈可拉倒吧
Jake: Hahaha, forget it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: We can do it.
Jake:插点电插点电
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in.
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Get me a power bank.
Lucia:我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Get me a power bank.
Shure: 这首歌叫啥来着
Shure: What's this song called again?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Katrina: 还没唱难忘今宵呢
Katrina: Haven't sung "Unforgettable Tonight" yet.
Katrina: 难忘今宵哎
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight," hey.
Katrina: 我觉得可以
Katrina: I think it's good.
Nicous: 这个好
Nicous: This is good.
Katrina: 我们还可以采取春晚的那种
Katrina: We can do it like the Spring Festival Gala.
修厦:上春山是吧
Shure: Go on the Spring Mountain, right?
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And then,
Lucia:然后再大合唱了
Lucia: And then we do a big chorus.
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: That works, that works.
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: Each person sings one line, less work.
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17.
Jake:17没事多很多
Jake: 17 is fine, a lot more.
Lucia:我信你
Lucia: I trust you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:没事没事不开玩笑
Lucia: No worries, just kidding.
Jake:那我给你三个
Jake: I'll give you three then.
Lucia:行行行用完了我随时换
Lucia: Okay, okay, I'll switch them anytime.
Katrina: 对但你可以拿双筷子吗
Katrina: Right, but can you get a pair of chopsticks?
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a treasure.
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: I'll give you a treasure.
Shure: 谢谢宝
Shure: Thanks, treasure.
Katrina: 海遇恋好像是那个谁的
Katrina: "Sea Encounter Love" seems to be by someone.
Katrina: 很老的一首歌
Katrina: A very old song.
Katrina: 你们有推荐的吗
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 就是开头比较欢快的
Katrina: Like something cheerful at the beginning.
Katrina: 你把那几个弹给他们听一遍呗
Katrina: Play those few songs for them to hear.
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: "Happy Superman."
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone,
Lucia:那个再见吧妈妈吗
Lucia: Is it "Goodbye, Mom"?
Shure: 什么是快乐星球
Shure: What is "Happy Planet"?
Katrina: 开心超人弹
Katrina: Play "Happy Superman."
Jake:每人拧一个
Jake: Everyone twist one.
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'm washing my hands.
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just came back from the hospital.
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: Don't dare to touch the food directly.
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this the "Happy Superman" song?
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Ah, yes.
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why do I feel so sad?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: I can...
Katrina: 哎哎要怎么吃
Katrina: Hey, hey, how do you eat this?
Tasha:还先蘸这个再蘸这个
Tasha: First dip it in this, then dip it in that.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 可是我刚刚舔过来的
Shure: But I just licked it.
Katrina: 哈哈你算了
Katrina: Haha, never mind.
Tasha:蘸蘸汤
Tasha: Dip it in the soup.
Tasha:蘸蘸再蘸一蘸啊
Tasha: Dip it again, and again.
Tasha:然后蘸蘸这个
Tasha: Then dip it in this.
Jake:唉呀妈呜
Jake: Oh my god.
Shure: 有毒有毒
Shure: It's toxic, it's toxic.
Katrina: 黏黏的
Katrina: It's sticky.
Shure: 我没蘸东西
Shure: I didn't dip anything.
Katrina: 我没有词汇量
Katrina: I have no vocabulary.
Katrina: 我太屌了
Katrina: I'm too cool.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Katrina: 香
Katrina: Smells good.
Alice:轩
Alice: Xuan.
Katrina: 嗯轩啊
Katrina: Hmm, Xuan.
Alice:轩啊
Alice: Xuan.
Shure: 轩哈哈
Shure: Xuan, haha.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:来
Jake: Come.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:嗯来了来了来
Jake: Hmm, here it comes.
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia: Thanks, hmm.
Lucia:年糕吗
Lucia: Is it rice cake?
Alice:麻薯
Alice: It's mochi.
Jake:看看这个店
Jake: Look at this shop.
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Tasha:豆乳的和可可的
Tasha: Soybean and cocoa.
Lucia:啊谢谢吃一个
Lucia: Ah, thanks, I'll try one.
Katrina: 他0.5倍速
Katrina: He's at 0.5 speed.
Lucia:可以蘸着吗
Lucia: Can I dip it?
Tasha:要多蘸
Tasha: Dip a lot.
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: The bowl's going to get dipped away.
Katrina: 开心往前飞
Katrina: Happy, flying forward.
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia:我是不是跟奶油有什么仇啊
Lucia: Do I have some kind of grudge against cream?
Shure: 多少多少学费
Shure: How much is the tuition?
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh? What?
Shure: 最重要
Shure: The most important thing.
Tasha:什么不要学费
Tasha: What, no tuition fee?
Lucia:我感觉我又该洗裤子了
Lucia: I feel like I need to wash my pants again.
Lucia:我好像跟奶油有仇似的
Lucia: It's like I have a grudge against cream.
Tasha:好那给我二成
Tasha: Okay, then give me a 20% cut.
Tasha:分成吧我亲力教教学
Tasha: Let's split it, I'll personally teach.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go to places with many Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He asked if there's competition.
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: Of course there's competition.
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: Just go to places with a lot of Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Isn't there a market then?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: It's not much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is big.
Jake:没关系不要看了
Jake: It's okay, don't worry about it.
Lucia:我先放一下
Lucia: I'll put it down for now.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Go get one done.
Lucia:拿瓶水
Lucia: Get a bottle of water.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a store.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:我刚看了
Lucia: I just checked.
Jake:喝喝好的
Jake: Drink it, it's fine.
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine.
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, it can be reimbursed.
Jake:报了
Jake: It's covered.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Lucia:能算工伤吗
Lucia: Can it be counted as a work injury?
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I'm even expecting to get two more shots after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: Didn't go to Xinjiang to study.
Tasha:不是这个不是在哪里学
Tasha: No, it's not about where to study.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: It's not about where to study.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Oh, you're not listening.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Alright, we can do it later.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Everyone, um...
Tasha:会发烧的
Tasha: You will get a fever.
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Please help me freeze some ice water, haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it should be fine.
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you're hurt.
Lucia:这个就是他
Lucia: This is just...
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: It's still red even now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look at this part.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, it seems a bit better than this afternoon.
Tasha:都是假的呵呵呵
Tasha: It's all fake, haha.
Lucia:就我特还有点
Lucia: I'm still kind of...
Jake:OKOK
Lucia:就我确实还有点红然后
Lucia: I'm still kind of red, and...
Katrina: 我当时还特崇拜你来
Katrina: I used to admire you a lot.
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, no big deal.
Katrina: 不是说只只只只是那个店是假的吗就
Katrina: Didn't they say the shop is fake?
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically it shouldn't be a big issue, but...
Jake:多打几针几挺好
Jake: Getting a few more shots would be good.
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is you need at least 4 or 5 shots.
Shure: 哎呀完了腿麻了动不了了
Shure: Oh man, my leg's numb, I can't move.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: At least 4 shots.
Shure: 我靠 哇
Shure: Damn, wow.
Lucia:就是打5针
Lucia: That's 5 shots.
Lucia:就是28天
Lucia: In 28 days.
Lucia:然后隔多久
Lucia: And then...
Shure: 我靠动不了你帮我拿一会
Shure: Damn, I can't move, can you help me?
Lucia: 隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot every week.
Shure: 我操腿麻了
Shure: Damn, my leg's numb.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, you need two today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: Yeah, so I got one on each side.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I got scratched by a cat before.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: And I was living in an Airbnb in the US.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: And got scratched by a cat there.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: And then grab it and...
Shure: 没有可乐了
Shure: There's no more cola.
Shure: 你的可乐就是我的可乐
Shure: Your cola is my cola.
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I talked to the landlord about it.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: And then, well, I was...
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Although I was really nervous on the first day, I eventually stopped worrying.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, I even went to the café today to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if this puppy had a vaccination record.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: And they said, well, they said...
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: The dog hasn't been taken for its shots yet.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the kennel said it had been vaccinated.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But the kennel didn’t give them the vaccination record.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: So I thought, maybe we should just take it for the shots.
Jake:还是不够踏实对
Jake: It's still not reassuring, right?
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So, I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family.
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend has a cat.
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by their cat.
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: So they went for the shots too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我说可以去采一个吧
Shure: I said maybe we should just get it done.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 如果不打的话怎么样
Tasha: What happens if we don’t get the shots?
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: So, I was thinking...
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: Like, I might get it done quickly, you know.
Jake:我之被抓的时候
Jake: When I got scratched...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:那种大长狗
Jake: That big dog...
Jake:那小狗没听就没听见
Jake: The little dog didn’t hear it.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 我说如果没有打疫苗得上狂犬病会怎么样
Tasha: I said, what if you get rabies if you don’t get vaccinated?
Lucia:我们打算开始之前打算回来了
Lucia: We planned to get it done before we came back.
Tasha: 马上死掉
Tasha: You’ll die immediately.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because it’s actually quite close by.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 百分百致死率
Katrina: Rabies has a 100% fatality rate.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: Yeah, but that's because he was on duty.
Katrina: 如果你得了是前题
Katrina: If you get it, that's the prerequisite.
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: So I had to wait a bit.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 这么恐怖
Tasha: That's so scary.
Lucia:那个医生
Lucia: The doctor.
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: And then I need to consult him about what's going on.
Katrina: 那概率还很低
Katrina: The probability is very low.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后怎么打
Lucia: And how to administer it.
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So it was a little late.
Jake:打个电话
Jake: Make a call.
Shure: 嘿Siri换疫苗多少钱一根
Shure: Hey Siri, how much is the vaccine per dose?
Jake:那个电话
Jake: That call.
Katrina: 疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is the vaccine per shot?
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is your vaccine per shot?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play a sound on my iPhone.
Lucia:基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's basically 100 yuan per shot.
Katrina: 哦那还很便宜
Katrina: Oh, that's quite cheap.
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: Yeah, but you need to get five or four shots.
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: If it's four shots,
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: you need to get two shots on the first day.
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: One in each arm.
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: The price of the vaccine varies?
Shure: 导航啊
Shure: Navigation.
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yeah, there's also a 300 yuan one.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:但我觉得310只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 310 yuan is a bit too much.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:而且就是
Lucia: And also,
Shure: 你要把所有的全住了
Shure: You need to fill all of it.
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Aren't their functions all to inhibit?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there something that inhibits faster?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Seems like there's no difference.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:应该是没啥区别
Lucia: There shouldn't be much difference.
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they choose which vaccine to give you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between 100 something and 300 something?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: I have no idea.
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We got it before.
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: Just finished one, and it was almost 2,000.
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Pick a song, pick a song, pick a song.
Lucia:哦那你可能那
Lucia: Oh, then maybe...
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because that place is actually quite close.
Lucia:那你那那就是你说的这种可能是300一针的
Lucia: Then what you said might be 300 per shot.
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Pick a song quickly.
Katrina: 定完歌睡觉了
Katrina: After we pick a song, we can sleep.
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's 300 each, then it's 1,500, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep.
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one seems to be three shots.
Katrina: 定完歌写论文哎
Katrina: After we pick a song, I'll write my paper.
Lucia:三针
Lucia: Three shots.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Katrina: 他们要严逼了
Katrina: They will be strict.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend got it too.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was also 100 per shot.
Lucia:然后我觉得这应该就可以了
Lucia: And I think that should be fine.
Jake:OKOKOKOK
Jake: OK, OK, OK, OK.
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: Why not listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: It should sound good as a chorus.
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: I hope I don't get a fever tonight.
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect might be a fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, you mean a fever from the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yes, a fever from the vaccine.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to the song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to the song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard this song?